[Music]
I need you to stay quiet this is a me
thing it is not a wee thing got that
fine but make it quick
one of I think our great hopes for
future films is other articulations of
denim as fans the comics will no
Carnage's the bond between Cletus Kasady
a serial killer and the red symbiote and
so this movie will introduce Cletus
Kasady hi Eddie carnage is the promise
of the venom character taken to the next
level so you know going into venom you
were hoping that there'd be carnage and
they delivered in a very delightful way
that made you go alright I'll give you
more of my money if you do this again
welcome back everyone its charlie we
have a whole bunch of new venom carnage
and spider-man stuff to talk about
they're currently filming venom two
right now Tom Hardy's been posting some
previews from behind the scenes so we'll
break it all down there's also news
about what's going on with spider-man if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
gonna be a lot of spider-man stuff
happening next year and we're doing a
Marvel giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best spider-man venom theory on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this so obviously in that clip
they're just talking about setting up
the carnage character at the end of the
venom movie just teasing a big venom
versus carnage fight it started that as
a pretty simple concept but now it's
become a much bigger thing because of
all the Marvel and Sony stuff that
happened this past summer so for a
little while we all saw spider-man left
the MCU Tom Holland says that he got
really drunk at a pub got on the phone
with Bob Iger Disney CEO and cried about
bringing spider-man back to the MCU and
doing right by the fans Bob Iger gets on
the phone with the Sony president and
they fix everything
spider-man is back in the MCU with a
brand new sharing deal I'll play that
clip of Tom Holland talking about
getting drunk on the phone with Bob Iger
in a second hands down best way to bring
spider-man back into the MCU just get
rip-roaring drunk while you're talking
to one of the most powerful people in
the entertainment industry but the thing
that everybody had really been hoping
for this entire time is to finally see
spider-man show up in a movie with venom
see them crossover even if he's not
gonna wear the symbiote right away just
to see them together on screen would be
amazing before all the drama
it didn't seem like that was gonna be
realistic but now because of their new
sharing deal between Marvel and Sony it
actually seems like they are planning on
doing that way faster than we ever saw
so right now the venom 2 movie has been
shooting scenes that will be set in and
around New York City the movie itself is
filming in London but they're making
some scenes that they're filming right
now look like they're being shot in New
York City there's a couple big Easter
eggs and the stuff that they're doing
I'll explain that in a second but this
is that funny clip of Tom Holland
talking about getting drunk to save
spider-man I don't know we had a really
good plan with what we were gonna do
with Sony the future of spider-man was
still very bright
but it would have been a shame to take
him out the MCU you know where he
belongs and we've built such a strong
character in that world and it would
have been a shame to lose that but I'm
just really glad that we my
really glad you got drunk and got on the
phone with Bobby and then my family and
I went to the pub quiz and I get a phone
call from an unknown number and I'm have
a feeling on it I think this is Bob Iger
but I'm drunk and then he said there is
a world and where we can make this work
and then there was a bunch of phone
calls back and forth from Tom Rossman he
was really instrumental in the process
and and and it was really interesting
for me to have these two like studio
heads like what do you think well Bob's
I think Bob said you cried on the phone
is that oh wait you did you really I
didn't we I did you did a little bit
what if spider-man's finest saves
although I would not recommend getting
drunk on the phone with people that hold
the power over your contract so the
really cool stuff that's happening right
now on the venom set is that they're
filming scenes at the same Estes home
for boys most of you longtime spider-man
comic book fans and carnage fans will
recognize that that is the orphanage
where Cletus Kasady was raised as a boy
so presumably there's either gonna be a
flashback there or they'll have an
action scene there said in present day
and they're setting things in and around
New York City they're slowly moving the
venom character into the periphery of
where spider-man is remember what he
said during that venom carnage
post-credit scene when I get out of here
there's going to be carnage so in the
comics after Cletus Kasady got the
carnage symbiote one of the first things
he did when he went on his rampage was
destroy that orphanage if you haven't
heard anything about the Morbius movie
this Soni is doing - it's sort of a
venom spin-off movie with Jared Leto
playing the Morbius character from the
comics that movie is also supposed to
take place in and around New York City
so you could see that Sony was already
sort of intending on setting their venom
verse in and around New York City it
only made sense that eventually you
would start to see spider-man show up in
those films we had a really good plan
with what we're gonna do is Saudi the
future of spider-man was still very
bright whatever their long-term plan was
before the Sony Marvel drama originally
people assumed that we wouldn't see
spider-man's show up with venom in one
of those movies like maximum carnage
eventually for a long long time but that
might be happening way faster now
because of the terms of their new
sharing deal between Marvel and Sony
spider-man has two more MCU movies now
including spider-man
that'll be inside the MCU and then
there'll be a crossover movie during
Marvel phase four that they haven't
announced yet just mystery movie
speculate all you want about what that's
gonna be but right after the
powers-that-be confirmed the spider-man
was back in the MCU a little while ago
Tom Hardy separately posted this picture
of himself to his Instagram wearing a
spider-man iron spider costume so one is
kind of funny to see him do that but two
this was also happening while they were
ramping up to hire Andy Serkis and start
shooting the venom sequel so yup all
this spider-man and venom stuff
happening behind the scenes and suddenly
venom himself Tom Hardy is running
around inside an MCU costume earlier
this year while Kevin Feige was doing
press for spider-man far from home
before all the drama started he was
asked point-blank if Sony was gonna use
Tom Hollands spider-man in their venom
movies and he said yes probably but that
would be their deal and he wouldn't have
much involvement in it at the time most
of us just assumed that that meant he
was trying to say that venom would not
be part of the MCU so any spider-man
venom crossover would be sort of a
separate thing and they wouldn't
consider a cannon to the Marvel movies
he later changed his comments after the
spider-man drama when they signed that
new sharing deal his direct quote now
and this was published in deadline read
spider-man is now the only character who
can travel between cinematic universes
which is a joke about the Marvel MCU
multiverse and the way they intend on
handling spider-man jumping back and
forth between venom movies and MCU
movies and if that doesn't get you more
excited he was at Brazil Comic Con just
a couple weeks ago talking about Marvel
phase 4 he said that the multiverse
would be the future of the MCU
over the next several years their next
big story device that they're using the
way that all the Hollywood news trades
were explaining Marvel and Sony's
crossover plan for spider-man and venom
they called it a call and answer system
where spider-man would appear with venom
in a venom movie at some point Sony is
allowed to reference the events of the
MCU spider-man movies as much as they
want like Mysterio the vulture Avengers
endgame the snap him dying coming back
to life big things like that then after
that venom crossover movie that Sony
does when spider-man comes back into
another MCU movie again Marvel is
allowed to reference the stuff that
happened to him in that venom crossover
but from what they're saying Tom Hardy
himself won't jump back and forth
between MCU movies and Sony venom ooh
it'll just be Tom Holland jumping back
and forth between universes and they'll
treat it like a multiverse story like
the venom movies are happening in an
alternate universe Tom Hall had already
confirmed that there was a plan for
something like this in spider-man into
the spider burst he was going to record
scenes as if it was his version of MCU
spider-man appearing in a crossover in
that film they went up scrapping that
plan at the last minute but it just lets
you know that that's already how they
were intending on handling crossover oh
it's all part of this giant multiverse
right now as far as what the Sony people
and the Marvel people have said venom 2
is just them doing the carnage origin
story and venom versus carnage with a
couple lesser side characters thrown in
like they added the shriek character as
Cletus Cassidy's girlfriend before he
becomes carnage but if Tom Hardy himself
is teasing a little bit of MCU
spider-man just having some fun with the
fans in some of venom 2 will take place
in and around New York City early
prediction they start referencing actual
Tom Hollands spider-man at some point
during that film either in a
post-credits scene or in the background
of one of the scenes in New York like on
a newspaper the other really cool rumor
that's going around too is that Sony
intends on using Jay jonah Jameson the
new version that appeared at the end of
spider-man far from home is this sort of
thread through the Sony in the Marvel
films I'll do more venom and spider-man
videos as we start to learn more about
what's going on with the next movie but
leave your requests in the comments
below
congratulations david petraeus you're
the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details everyone click here for
that spider-man into the spider verse 2
teaser trailer and click here for my new
Mandalorian episode 6 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight